these people are over there HUD
embracing Farrakhan that'd be like a
Donald Trump high-fiving David Duke yeah
great job get your tiki torch so this is
my question for you today do you think
that Democrats the DNC that they're
trying right now they're trying to
distance themselves from these so-called
extremists we're going to go through
Louis Farrakhan in their ranks do you
think they're trying to distance
themselves more recently and is it even
possible considering that these
extremists are some of their most
important figure heads like what is a
moderate DNC look like let me know you
remove these people what do you have in
today's Democratic Party I I don't know
that you can so the latest is Farrakhan
people trying to distance themselves
from him for what some might call or
consider slightly tinge of anti-semitic
overtones here here's some clips the
Satanic Jews they control everything and
mostly everybody if they are you enemy
then you must must be somebody about the
wicked ones and in the Jewish community
that run America run the government run
the world meeting all the banks the
means of communication they are my
enemies but as sure as I'm alive my
enemies will be made my footstool here
the Jews
that's a Turkish one don't like
Farrakhan so they call me hidden well
that's a good name Hitler was a very
great man oh yeah but by the way if
you're waiting to go wall that's not a
good no watch the whole clip that pretty
much captures it I was ready when he
goes a compare me to Hitler I'm about to
use that defense like oh everyone I
disagree with this Hitler that's what
the left does all the time compare so I
would defend him until he goes I love
Hitler
I guess the comparison after comparison
she holds water so uh first stuff I
don't know if that's hair is just
lacquered down if it's painted on like
that the second girlfriend from Fresh
Prince at this point I have no idea but
Democrats have long buddied up with
Farrakhan okay this is one thing now
they're trying to distance themselves
from him but this is there's a
long-standing history here this is about
something that I think is important
just like Nancy Pelosi and Hillary
Clinton and then Bernie Sanders at black
lives matter you remove the crazies and
you remove all the activists right Roy
Moore gone from Republican but it
doesn't affect the Republicans at all
right
Donald Trump has half of the Republican
Party who thinks he's a boob but if you
remove all these activists from the left
there's no one left so here's one of the
more recently revealed photos with Obama
and an Farrakhan give me an idea as to
just how ingrained he was DNC chair
keith Ellison to the members of black
the Congressional Black Caucus attended
private dinner with Farrakhan you have
Tameka Mallory the co-president of
women's March the tenants of the
anti-semitic speeches Democratic
congressman they had regular meetings
with them here's actually I think a
video clip of members of the
Congressional Black Caucus embracing
Maxine Waters and Farrakhan here
it's not exactly just a meet she's on
his speed dial these people are over
their Hut embracing Farrakhan that'd be
like a Donald Trump high-fiving David
Duke yeah great job get your tiki torch
this is how bad it is so by the way hey
notification clicked the bell if you're
watching on YouTube because subscribe
doesn't mean anything now so click the
bell on the top left there in case you
want to hear about our new videos so
Democrats know they're trying to
distance themselves from Farrakhan but
they've been bedfellows with these
people for a long time it's not only
Farrakhan so al Sharpton has obviously
been in hot water
recently for his I guess anti-semitic
remarks so it's hard to know if he made
genuinely anti-semitic remarks Rafi just
had another stroke reading the
teleprompter Obama of course launched
his campaign for Senate at the home of
convicted terrorists Bill Ayers and
likely did cocaine with him in college
not to mention his passionate praise of
Black Liberation Theology Derrick Bell
very very radical not to mention of
course the praise of Saul Alinsky as for
the women's March again the we're
talking about all of the activist groups
we're talking about people who have
spearheading the modern leftist movement
the women's March that was the biggest
one I wasn't Joe Rogan learson this was
the biggest March that ever this is the
biggest activist that's the group that's
ever happened with with our with our
generation okay women's March it's not
just Tameka Mallory co-president of
women's March defender of Farrakhan but
also Linda Sarsour who was openly
anti-semitic and of course March
organizer we've talked about resmio day
is a convicted terrorist involved in a
bombing that killed two Jewish children
keyword they're convicted second keyword
if you want terrorists you know what
killed you Jewish children five keywords
yes I think you're not isolated
incidents this is a pattern and it
really seems to me I don't know what you
guys think and I really would love to
hear your seems to me that without the
help of the radical extreme far left
today's progressive base would cease to
exist there are no activists outside of
Occupy and the Bernie socialist and the
black lives matter activists and the
[ __ ] hat women's marchers the activists
on the right as corny as they may be
right you have the tea the biggest one
would be the tea partiers wanting lower
taxes business owners and entrepreneurs
pushing for more business friendly
environments even yeah the crazy
Christian whack jobs and the worst they
might push for is not want and their
kids to be handed rubbers and wooden
phalluses on a school bus okay veteran
of the American worker these people make
up the rights
to this base you may not like who they
necessarily vote for but these are the
people who make up the grassroots the
radical left the Farrakhan to the
sharpens the Linda Sarsour
yes even the shaved headed girl from
parkland Florida who looks like the
Minority Report Oracle demanding the
banning of all semi-automatic rifles you
remove these nutcases the left has no
one left to mobilize them hey did you
enjoy this video here's the thing you
wrote you're here this is the end of the
so we don't care cuz you already watched
it but if you really didn't like it and
you want to justify it leave a comment
below telling us why you didn't like the
video and if you liked us let us know
and subscribe to the channel because
that lets the overlords at YouTube know
that you know what you're alright